you know i tend to subscribe to the to
the idea that you should expect the
worst and hope for the best but then
also know that your hopes are foolish
and futile and then resign yourself to
despair and failure this may not be the
healthiest psychological approach to
life you know it's not going to make you
the most joyful person but it inoculates
you from disappointment at any rate and
um that is why i didn't expect good news
honestly to come from the supreme
court's hearing on biden's vaccine
mandate i wasn't expecting
good news it was worth fighting we had
to fight but i i have little faith in
the court's ability to get anything
right
so i was prepared for the worst
and for once for once my pessimism was
not vindicated
as you've heard by now the court
announced on thursday that it was
blocking
biden's vaccine mandate for private
employers effectively killing it for
good even if the the sixth circuit rules
in favor of the mandate at some point in
the coming months which maybe they will
the supreme court has already made its
opinion known on the subject which means
that this mandate simply has no path
forward it will never see the light of
day it might linger on in the court
system for a while but it won't make its
way
out into the workforce where you have to
worry about it
why did the court block the mandate
well you can read the opinions which are
which are actually worth reading
but it all amounts to what we already
knew
the federal government has no
constitutional authority to impose this
kind of rule onto the american workforce
biden cannot unilaterally declare that a
certain medical decision
must be a prerequisite for employment
for every person in the country he
doesn't have that authority the mandate
was illegal it was also deeply immoral
as it sought to violate the autonomy
of the individual in a really profound
way you know we hear a lot about bodily
autonomy as it relates to issues that
have nothing to do with bodily autonomy
like abortion
but here is one where the phrase is
actually useful the president trying to
force a needle into your arm
for any reason at all
must be an infringement on your autonomy
if you have any autonomy at all if that
word means anything then it must apply
here and on top of being illegal and
immoral it's also illogical
this point was not uh featured as
prominently in the supreme court
arguments but it's important
even decisive i think since the shot
does not prevent the spread of the virus
anyway
and
any any even potential argument
justifying the mandate melts away into
oblivion
if the mandate could be justified at all
which which couldn't
but if it could that justification would
have to rest on the vaccine's ability to
stop the spread
that's the only way you could say that
there's any real public health interest
going on here
but it has no such ability not a
significant enough degree anyway and uh
and so the one potential defense of the
mandate is rendered moot so it has no
legs to stand on
and now it can't stand at all because
it's been shot down
now i do believe it's necessary to spike
the football
when you achieve a victory
for one thing because it's just so damn
satisfying to do
but two because it's important to
acknowledge uh the wins when they come
and this is a big one the daily wire was
first in line to challenge the mandate
in court soon followed by many other
employers and organizations not enough i
mean there were
most employers were willing to just go
along with it
and not fight at all
but you know we've been chanting do not
comply for months
and it's more than a slogan for a
t-shirt it's a battle cry now a victory
cry and a banner that we're going to
continue to march under into the future
because too many people have grown far
too accustomed
to simply doing as they're told
going along to get along cooperate
submit
so they don't make any waves so they
don't draw unwanted attention to
themselves
but if we're going to pull our society
back from the brink
and rescue ourselves from civilizational
ruin
we need to just rediscover the power of
the word no
that's what the daily wires mandate
challenge was all about we said no and
the no prevailed in this case
now it doesn't end here
because the tyrants will never stop
exploiting kovid in an effort to gain
more power for themselves
and beyond kovad we know that there are
many more battles to fight
if we will not comply has been our
battle cry of the daily wire for years
you know for years before that the
battle cry or rather the cry of
surrender among the losers and
submissives and bootlickers of our
culture has been
this isn't the hill to die on
you know they're constantly accusing
those of us who are in the fight the the
men in the arenas teddy roosevelt said
of dying on a hill do you really want to
die on this hill they sputter helplessly
and as each successive hill is reached
they always find reasons why it's not
important enough to fight over
surrendering one hill after another
until there are none left to defend
so to answer that question yeah we will
die on this hill
and the next one
and the one after that if that's what it
takes
because we've given up far too much
ground culturally
and and we aren't willing to be a part
of the retreat
so we're standing our ground and the
great thing we've discovered about being
willing to die on the hill
is that sometimes you win you don't die
and you get to pop champagne and
celebrate your victory
other times you lose
but you go down swinging
and you cause as much damage to your
opponent as you can on your way down
setting the stage for the next fight
that's my attitude that's why i'm here
at the daily wire because it's an
attitude shared by the whole company we
won this fight
can't promise that we'll always win
you know they're going to be losses too
we can promise that we'll always fight
and that means something
i mean these days i think it means
everything really
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content